you just saw this over the weekend with
Disney Disney just had the historic
first
hold on let me see what the history it's
the historic first gay teen romance
animated film it's called strange world
it's the historic first though I thought
wait hold on how many how many times now
have I read the headline historic first
gay blank from Disney
I mean you had Disney Executives on
leaked video saying that they were
pushing a not so secret gay agenda there
have been gay kisses in this thing and
gay relationships in this thing and gay
this and gay that but I guess because
this one's an underage gay relationship
that's the big new historic first and it
totally flopped
the the movie brought in 4.2 million
dollars in ticket sales they're
projecting that it could make as little
as 21 million dollars over the full uh
holiday weekend
the movie was 180 million dollar budget
so it's just a complete failure so why
is that because the people don't want to
see it of course not you can be totally
open-minded and Live and Let Live and
you're not homophobic or anything at all
and you don't want to go take your kid
to see like cartoon gay teenagers
kissing right they just not something
that people want but but the
conservatives don't
unfortunately the conservatives don't
recognize the game that is being played
here and they they want to allow the the
cultural revolution to to go halfway
they don't want to totally stand against
the cultural revolution but they don't
want it to go all the way either they
want it to stop halfway if you stand in
the middle of the road though you will
in fact be hit by a truck
the the reason that
the the Disney teen gay movie failed is
because people don't want to see it
but the reason it was made in the first
place is that the entire culture has
normalized homosexuality
but the problem is if you normalize
homosexuality then you you have to
normalize it for young people too
this is where I actually think that the
left makes stronger arguments than the
right
if homosexual behavior is totally normal
totally fine no questions about it
whatsoever Christianity Judaism Islam
every
many pagans everyone who is though not
those Greeks they got a little frisky
with each other but if
there are any people who've ever thought
about these questions we're all totally
wrong and there's no moral question
whatsoever about homosexual Behavior
then
then why shouldn't it be normalized for
teenagers too
people develop romantic feelings when
they're teenagers
people go on little dates and they have
little crushes and they flirt with each
other when they're teenagers
so why why would we now be saying well
no you're only allowed to have
representations of crushes and dates and
teen romances for straight couples not
gay couples
why would we that wouldn't make any
sense
unless you were to go all the way and
say no homosexuality is abnormal and
maybe we'll be open-minded about it and
we're not going to be cruel and we're
not going to be mean we're not going to
be vicious and all these different
things but we have to acknowledge it's
abnormal it is not the norm not what
we're aiming at okay and therefore we're
not going to present it in our popular
culture we're not going to make every
single movie and every single thing gay
all the time and we're certainly not
going to present teenage teenagers in
these gay relationships in cartoons
but I don't think the conservatives are
willing to go there
I don't do you
no because it feels icky and you know
that you'll be called phobic or this or
that and it it also rubs up against
pun unintended it rubs up against
a liberal premise that that many
American conservatives have adopted
which is that politics is ultimately
just about the individual individual
Choice individual preference do whatever
you want to do as long as it doesn't
hurt me just do whatever you want to do
I have no right to come in and tell you
not to do that the state certainly has
no right to come in and tell you not to
do that
you just have a sort of radical
individual autonomy
now that is not traditionally a
conservative point of view that is a
liberal point of view okay that that is
the consequences of John Locke okay
the conservatives traditionally tend to
go a little more for the Aristotle idea
you know they tend to go a little bit
more for the idea that man is a
political being or a social being we
obviously are influenced by one another
there obviously are norms and standards
in society and there always will be and
so we need to just agree on what those
are and hopefully we have better
standards and not worse standards right
I don't the reason that I think the libs
are going to win is not because the libs
are omnipotent
or the libs are so smart or the libs
what I think the reason that the libs
right now are more likely to win on
these cultural issues is because the
conservatives
don't have any Clarity on it and they
don't they don't they don't see
they don't see how far back on the
slippery slope you gotta go
to stop this sort of stuff because it's
a pretty far ways back
and so as a result this movie is going
to bomb and you know what you're going
to get another gay teen cartoon and that
one's probably going to bomb to and
you're gonna get another gay teen
cartoon it's just going to keep going
because the libs are determined to
normalize this sort of thing and the
conservatives are not going to resist it
a very very effective way
as I mentioned to to amass power is to
claim victimhood so a lot of this uh
came out of AIDS when during the AIDS
epidemic you saw lots of gay guys dying
and this created a lot of public
sympathy rightly so and as a result of
that you saw a huge leap
in the gay gay rights movement and then
ultimately that leads to redefining
marriage and ultimately that leads to
transgenderism
but sometimes because this is an effect
of political tactic
sometimes people just fake it a lot of
times people just fake it actually so
over the last month there's a gay bar in
Hell's Kitchen it's called verz v-e-r-s
verse
and they've had four separate incidents
of an individual throwing bricks Through
the Windows
awful terrible homophobic attack right
well according to Borough president in
New York
the epidemic of lgbtq plus violence is
National a well-known gay bar on
Manhattan's west side has been attacked
repeatedly in recent weeks we cannot
stand for this according to a city
council member this man and they show a
picture of the guy this man has thrown
bricks at the window of verse bar four
times in recent weeks
these are hate crimes against the lgbtq
community as opposed to love crimes you
know they hate the hate ones not the
loved ones please help us identify him
if you have any information please
contact NYPD hate crimes at this address
or this number
now this was going a little too far with
the city council member because he
showed the picture it was a little bit
of a video
they found the guy
the guy is not being charged with a hate
crime
why is he not being charged for the hate
crime because he is not a homophobe how
do we know he's not a homophobe because
he is a gay guy
it was a gay guy doing it and so now the
story goes away
there was that shooting at the gay club
in Colorado
the moment the shooting happened
obviously it's very sad whenever
shooting happens but the moment it
happened you had this flood from the
left wing media
they said this is a homophobic attack
this is the result of people like those
over at the daily wire
who opposed the lgbtq agenda this is
there's a few of blood on your hands
all you evil conservatives
then what happened
turns out the shooter is a member of the
lgbtq community and the shooter
identifies as non-binary and then and
then what happened the story completely
disappeared
completely disappeared okay
it was just Jessie Smollett
Jesse this is a homophobic anti-black
attack in the south side of Chicago
which is Maga country and there were
white supremacists with nooses okay this
isn't totally checking out but they
still push the story and then when it
became clear he made the whole thing up
story just went away
and it's important for people to
recognize this when you're reading the
news
you you have to recognize that
yes the stories are probably not being
reported accurately
so yes they spread fake news in that way
but it goes even further the only reason
you are seeing certain stories
is to push an agenda
newspapers have editors Okay the reason
that these stories end up there in the
first place the reason you've heard of
these stories is because they're pushing
an agenda
you see this in every news story forget
about the gay stuff or the race stuff or
whatever you see this with the war in
Ukraine
why is it that the war in Ukraine is the
only war that anyone's really heard
about in recent years
it's not because it's the only war going
on there are plenty of Wars going on in
Arabia in Africa in Asia there are Wars
going on all over the place
you're hearing about that war because
it more directly involves the United
States even though the U.S doesn't want
to admit it
and two because the the West feels a uh
at interest the United States feels a
national interest in that war and so
you're seeing a ton of it that's that is
why that is appearing to you and it's
why it's even in your own perception
okay
so
it helps to be able to see through these
sorts of things and and when you see
shifts in power that's especially when
it becomes clear because all of the
things that that the side that was in
power have been whining on and rattling
on about for months and months and years
and years all of a sudden when they
totally back away from them
you realize how hollow their players
were to begin with
[Music]